في امريكا شوف في امريكا في يعني طرفين
في القياده الفكريه والقياده السياسيه في
طرف وهو المهيمن للاسف الان يريد اعداء او
يخلق عدو من الصين يعني ان يعيد ان يعيد
تاريخ الحرب البارده وان يبدل الاتحاد
السوفيتي بالصين انه الصين هو الان العدو
الكبير ولازم انه كل طاقات امريكا
العسكريه واستراتيجيه كلها ان تتجه
لعداء الصين او لمعاداه الصين انا ارى خطر
كبير في هذا الفكر وفي هذا المنحه
والاتجاه اولا الصين علاقتها بامريكا
مختلفه عن ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي لانه في
علاقات اقتصاديه يعني كبيره بين بين
الطرفين ومن الصعب جدا انه خلق الشرخ هذا
بين البلدين
اضافه ولكن في نفس الوقت هذا يصب في مصالح
كبيره امريكيه ان كانت في المصالح عسكريه
مصالح الصناعيه الى اخره بايدن من محبيذي
هذا الفكر العدائي اتجاه الصين ترامب لم
يكن كذلك يعني في عداء تجاه الصين ولكن في
كمان ممكن انه يتعامل معها
فانا ارى انه المملكه والدول الاخرى مثل
مثل الاعنف سلوك من امريكا تحاول
بالقوانين بالحرب التجاريه بغيرها من
الامور اليس كذلك كان في صحيح لانه لانه
هو لانه هو شاف انه الصين كانت بتاخذ كل
كل العماله يعني كل كل الوظائف من امريكا
الى الصين بس لكن عدائه كان عداء اقتصادي
ما هو عداء ايديولوجي او عداء يعني هو ما
عنده عداء تجاه الصين لاسباب ايديولوجيه
اوكي او عسكريه واضح هو يريد ان يعيد كل
كل الوظائف هذه اللي راح ت الى الصين
ويعيدها الى امريكا مصلحه السعوديه
قطبيه دكتور تكون فيها امريكا والصين
وروسيا وغيرها من الدولار
هو يعني هو بايدن التعدديه القطبيه عند
انه في دول في عالم ديموقراطي وفي عالم
استبداد في عالم يعني اوتوكراطي هم يسمونه
هذا يعني هذا
يعني التفسير للعالم يعني ما هو قائم على
على واقع لانه في دول
مثل نقول تركيا او الهند هي شبه استبداديه
ولكن هي حليفه امريكا فيعني
التصوير هذا للعالم يعني تبسيط جدا لمصالح
امريكا وما بيخدم مصالح امريكا وفي دول
مثل مثل المملكه مثلا
ما عليهم ان يختاروا بين الصين وامريكا
يريدون ان ان يكون لهم علاقه مع البلدين
مش بس المملكه يعني في دول اخرى حتى في
اسرائيل في مصر في تركيا في الهند
فرض
المنظومه هذه منظومه انه الصين هو العدو
الاول والاخير
انا اعتقد انه خطر جدا على امريكا وعلى
العالم سؤالي لك حول الاخير حول السودان
دكتور في الوقت الذي بدانا نشعر فيه بحاله
من من التهدئه في المنطقه بعد المصالحات
اللي جرت اشتعلت السودان بشكل مفاجئ مع
انه من كان يتحكم في كل المسارات خلال في
السودان المتازمه اصلا يعني هي الولايات
المتحده والرباعيه الدوليه يعني بشكل كبير
وكانت تستطيع بالفعل ان تتعامل مع مع
البرهان ممثله للجيش مع القوى السياسيه
المدنيه وكذلك مع حميدتي طرفي الصراع يعني
فبالتالي هل من مصلحه امريكيه في اشعال
الوضع في السودان في المنطقه
لا اعتقد انا بصراحه انا ارى انه مصلحه
امريكا هي قريبه جدا من مصلحه المملكه وهي
انه تهدئه المنطقه وعدم اشعال الحروب في
المنطقه وحتى بصراحه هو نفس
هذه كمان مصلحه الصين يعني الصين تريد ان
النفط من الخليج ان ياتي اليها ومن دون اي
حروب او مشاكل وكذا انا ارى انه في تقاطع
بصراحه بالمصالح
بين امريكا وبين المملكه اكيد يعني في
موضوع السودان وفي المنطقه عموما وهو
الاستقرار
وعدم اشعال الحروب وارى انه اضافه الى ذلك
انه الصين في المنطقه بخلاف مثلا تايوان
موضوع تايوان هنا لا يتقاطع بين في
المصالح ولكن في المنطقه في تقاطع بين
مصالح امريكا والصين وهو الاستقرار
وتخليص من من كل القوى والدول التي تريد
ان تزعزع
الحاله الامنيه في المنطقه ومنها اكيد
ايران